more Griffin back again
and you know how we do
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
to your favorite podcast
what's up y'all welcome Chad welcome
everybody live back to your favorite
podcast ripping with Griffin on today's
episode I review this show on Apple TV
called Invasion I really like it
um get caught up on the lizzo story man
it's just it's not looking good for her
um and a bunch of news and notes around
the world you know you know how I do we
do it live off the cuff these are things
in my head I might even talk about the
rider strike sag strike but either way
you know what's always 100 percent
I lost my breath on that one
ah you know it's not always it's not
always perfect y'all
but it's always authentically Eric
Griffin Riven with Griffin so hello
everybody hello to all of my fans all of
my trolls and haters I know you're here
too
um this is ripping with Griffin uh
comedy podcast that's not always comedy
but it is always 100 me off the cuff so
welcome if you're a first time viewer
thanks for being here if you're a long
time listener you know how we do so make
sure you hit the Subscribe button so you
know I go live on um
I go live on uh what do you call it uh
Wednesdays sometime between 10 and 2.
you never know because you know life
gets in the way man
um so make sure you subscribe you know
hit me on Twitch if you like if you like
to watch gaming just come watch me game
I'm there it's a lot of fun it's really
more about like all the chatting and the
smack talk that goes on on the gaming
channel patreon yeah oh my you know what
I just reminded myself that I forgot to
do my uh two review videos that I was
gonna do for patreon I just been so busy
but I will keep you uh posted on what's
going on in my world so
welcome to Griffin with Griffin
live from the Griffin Studios
um wait let me go here real quick
because I want to go to my profile I
want to thank everybody for uh being
here as always
um so all right anyways uh nice if
you're live thanks for Apple listeners
Amazon listeners whatever you listen to
the podcast I appreciate that support
too and I would love a comment
especially on Apple you know it helps
the algorithm helps push it out you know
my my small But Mighty podcast that I
appreciated you guys come
every week and whatnot okay so first up
what's been going on with me uh there's
not no no real pregnancy news uh you
know Rachel's like we're like we're in
month four you know
16 weeks you know it's like
Trucking along she's not as sick as she
she was so it's like it's better like we
you know we went to the movies and that
kind of thing but you know it is what it
is it's like it's it's I just am amazed
every day at
you know as I see her and think to
myself wow this is what women go through
to you know make a life and it's just
such a what it does to their body what
it does to their emotions and it's just
like man
Kudos shout out to all women man it's uh
I don't I I don't I wouldn't be able to
do it you know what I mean so it is
something else man
so there's that
um what did I do so this past weekend I
was in Ohio
so I don't know if you I mean I guess
some of you know some of you may not
know but like you know one of my one of
my good buddies
um who I've known now for a long time is
Matt Rife you know I've known Matt since
he was like 16 years old you know what I
mean and so here we I went to Ohio with
him because he's working on a new
special and you know I know him very
well so it's like he wanted me to come
out and like look at his set and like
you know just like give him some notes
and thoughts and like help him like you
know when he comes up with something to
be like Oh I like that boom boom boom
and then even in the it what was great
is at the end of The Late Show towards
the end he we went on stage together
because he told the crowd like hey I'm
working out in this material and I like
to brainstorm it's okay I bring Eric out
so then him and I were just on stage
together and it's just like I he's like
a grown ass man now you don't understand
why I knew this guy when he was you know
15 16 years old and he would messed up
teeth and wearing a backwards hat and
skinny and scrawny and now he's like a
man and a boss you know he's got
employees and he like he's in charge of
himself and I I can't tell you enough
how proud I am
seeing that like and now he's just a you
know multi-millionaire you know what I
mean it's like he's on a sold out
two-year tour that's sold out the whole
tour is sold out two years people are
buying tickets nine months year ahead of
time to go see this dude
and he puts on a great show you know he
doesn't disappoint you know it's like
it's like all the girls in the crowd
that are there because they're so
attracted to him they they you can see
that they're actually having a good time
the boyfriends who don't even want to be
there because their girlfriends made
them come by the end of the show they're
having a good time because they're like
yeah man because he's like not what you
think you know and so it's really it's
really good to see and so I'm gonna I'm
going again this weekend with him he's
going to be in Atlantic City at some big
theater you know it's already sold out
so you know I don't know what to tell
you if you're trying to go but it's like
I don't know it's amazing not everybody
would do what I'm doing in my position
you know like Matt used to go on the
road with me he would get you know what
I mean and then like here I am now like
oh yeah he said hey you want to come I
wish I was like sure because like you
know I when you really truly care about
somebody when you really are like family
or good friends with someone
your ego don't get in the way of
anything you are supportive of the thing
and I support that I support him 100 and
so I will go do this I I know not
everybody in my position would do that
you know because you know people just
people are mostly lip service words
people care more about their own
self-interest you know what I mean
um
I love this
you know I don't know I don't know what
more to say it's just you know dude I
love this kid so if you get a chance to
go out and see them go out and see him
um but that's great you know
yeah somebody said Bobby open for Tom
yeah yeah yeah there's certain but what
I'm saying is this though
there's there are certain people who are
like so big that
it supersedes that you know like there
are certain people that are like if
somebody's in an arena you go okay I
could go do that this is a comedy club
you know what I mean it's like he just
became big like he still is dealing with
all the haters who don't think he
deserves it you know I love that he's
got this billboard on Sunset for his
tour and it's near The Comedy Store and
there's so many haters at The Comedy
Store who are just like oh yeah he's
just this and that you know and then
they have to drive to the comedy store
and see his billboard for his sold out
World Tour you know it's like you know
and he's young he's only 27 so it's like
people are still
you know people still think look this is
how comedy is supposed to be done that
kind of thing you know what I mean but
it's like
it's just it's actually I actually laugh
on my head now when I sit I'm standing
with somebody who starts to hate on him
because it happens a lot you'd be
surprised the comedy community is a
bunch of cowards
um you know what I mean just a bunch of
petty
Petty cowards you know a lot of them
and then they're like you know
saying whatever they're saying and then
you're just like okay all right so so
how should he do it so so it's like if
you give somebody the the two options
the first option is
put your air quotes up everybody you
know do it the right way whatever that
is right
okay so if you had the choice like you
know uh be like this like what you think
some respect you think you're getting by
doing comedy a certain way and no one
ever see it it's it never has Mass
Appeal at all
or go on a sold out tour where you're
going to make 40 million dollars you
tell me which one
that purist would pick
you know what I mean
it's like and then so
it's like I always tell Matt I'll be
like don't be Petty you know like don't
have a chip on your shoulder don't worry
about it because you won
you know it's like when you win you win
I believe he's gonna I believe he's on
Rogan I think he I think he's gonna be
on Rogan he's gonna be on sigura's
podcast so I want to see what the haters
are gonna say after that you know what I
mean so it is what it is much love to
the kid it is what it is all right so
let's go on to
um let's get some comments
let's get some comments you know how we
do we go to the comments
um
nate796 I stumbled on on you from Bobby
and you used to watch your more
colleagues in high school absolutely
need more entertainment reviews with
Yoda and grogu Bobby and Steve guys it's
never gonna happen okay
I know you guys love the the couple of
episodes I did with the Lee Brothers
it's done it's over that's why it hasn't
happened again in five years or however
long ago that was like episode 10 or
something like that that we did that
it's never gonna happen again okay uh
but thank you I appreciate you guys
still watching
those episodes all right
um forever hungry music this is a
comment about when I was talking about
you know the stuff on the internet it
says Eric spelled incorrectly which you
know that's annoying
Eric just so you know no parent really
knows what they are doing you realize
your parents didn't know either I have
two daughters one is eight and the other
is four we all worry if what we're doing
is the right way remember there's no
right way it's my way do it your way
because we are all learning as we go and
the comment goes on but I understand
exactly what you're saying about that
you know but it's like at least you have
some at least there's a shared community
of parents out there that like you know
that's the one of the good things about
the internet is you know people put
their information out there then you can
kind of parse through all of the the
different things and be like oh that
looks good you know especially like for
even if it's just like reviews of
products you know people might be like
hey we like these diapers for this
reason you know oh here's a little tip
when the baby's sleeping to do this you
know all these little things you could
pick up and at least at least that
knowledge is out there and you just have
to decide for yourself uh you know what
you think is
um
the the best thing so you know I mean I
get that you know it just
it's tough you know what I mean anyway
um
let's see oh then last week okay so a
lot of people made a comment about the
bear from last week where it looked like
a man in a suit right but apparently
that's been debunked so Noah Morado said
it's a real bear just Google bears
walking on two legs I can't believe that
many people actually think it's a damn
human in there the bear looks a little
skinny but Jesus get in tune with nature
more
so so let me let me get this straight
Noah you want us to get in tune with
nature
about the bear that's in a cage at the
zoo
[Laughter]
people like people like hearing
themselves talk in their head you know
and they just write things
because it sounds good you know in his
head he was like I'm gonna tell
everybody off
get in touch with nature
okay man but I know what you mean I'm
just teasing you
um
let's see
uh let's see Andrew
kodaleski three two three zero I don't I
know I didn't say that right he goes as
far as the con constant conflicting info
on the internet I feel you you feel you
it's extremely stressful as a parent
having to also somehow become a PhD on
every subject it's something I struggle
with but honestly it's trial and error
every generation has done things wrong
and yet most of us are right you already
know it's nuanced thank you and if
you're there and you're trying your best
and even and even do some research it
means you're on the right path it's
exactly what we're just talking about
you know so thanks man I appreciate that
uh
let's see
um yeah so somebody there's somebody
else this was four years ago do it again
please that's the Bobby and Steve one
four years ago I can't believe that was
four years
uh
let's see
some I don't know this there's a lot I
had I had a couple of comments
like like marked
um whatever but anyway thanks for the
comments and you know you guys in chat
too that are live commenting live if you
have questions and whatever you know let
me oh I forgot to do that let me let me
put that up and get ready to go with
that you know when you you know start my
q a
you know what you got y'all
so if you have something it you know put
your question in chat and I'll look I'll
look there too but anyways
um let's see what's going on uh this
week
nothing nothing too much like I said so
I'm doing this uh I'm doing this Indie
movie you know we got approved by sag
you know there's like 200 projects that
got approved
um to you know to because like so these
these independent projects are abiding
by what sag is asking for before
negotiations you know so it's actually
like so like sag is asking for say this
amount of money and they're asking for
this amount of residuals they're asking
for you know and and so they have that
on the table of what they're asking from
the studios and stuff right so if you
want to do an independent movie right
now you needed to follow those rules
you're saying okay we will we will um
pay you this amount and then and then
and then whoever buys the project
whoever buys the independent project
they also have to
abide by
this pre negotiated because it's like
probably a a higher rate than what when
when it's all said and done it's
probably going to be less than what
people are going to get but if they want
this project they're gonna have to pay
this
so
you know
and and
um
I I don't know sometimes I have mixed
feelings about it only because of like
weird perceptions that people have you
know it's like because like today they
just announced that sag is no longer
going to allow
they they just said stag after will no
longer approve Indie projects you know
because it's like there's so much
misinformation and so much backlash that
people are receiving because of it that
they're just like all right you know
what then nobody work and there was a
school of thought that that's what
people think it's like are we on strike
or not you know because people don't get
the information that like what these
small production companies with these
small Indie Productions are saying is
like this is not a lot with the actors
and writers are asking for so we're
willing to pay that why can't
the big companies that make you know
30 billion dollars a year why can't they
do that you know so that's but
you know the internet people cave you
know it's like it's so hard to parse
through all of the the information so
sag is just like you know what that's it
just nobody work that's just where
they're at now so it's tough because
we're about to start this thing you know
but regardless
it's a great little project uh the the
love the writer director I think she
even listens to my podcast
um I'm not going to say people's names
because of this whole thing too because
I don't want people to get hate for no
reason to you know misinformation but
you know anyone in one of the and uh so
this is okay let me I just want to give
you a little uh thing for me okay so
I've talked about this before like on my
podcast on the previous episodes it's
like you know when you're like you know
I'm usually like the funny guy you know
I'm usually like you know I'm comic
relief or I'll be like five six seven on
a call sheet you know as that person you
know what I mean so you have like the
stars and then you know here we go and
then like here I come doing my thing or
you I might or I might be in like an
ensemble cast like I'm dying up here
where there was like you know nine of us
right or however many there was you know
and you had people that were like oh
this is the star quote-unquote of the
show but I had an equal
I had equal parts in like a show like
that but you don't have to carry the
load because there's so many people but
this is going to be one of the first
times in this any movie where it's like
I think I'm number two on the call sheet
you know what I mean and it's like it's
a great story about you know a couple in
their 50s you know there's not a lot of
that stuff out there it's always
everybody's got to be young and it's
like but there are stories for people of
age that they want to see too and so I I
you know I commend the the the writer
director on especially against somebody
in their 50s it's like yeah I still want
to work I don't want to pretend to be 41
all the time right
39 you know what I mean cause I'm
looking good
um
you know so so then we started we've
been you know we've been like getting
together and kind of like going over the
the script and like you know so we had
this great thing yesterday where we were
like
uh go where are we gonna shoot and then
it was like all right so let's go
through some of the scenes and get to
know you know in the in the lead
actually she's great you know what I
mean uh you know and she's like but we
had these great talks but here's the
reason why I'm saying this when I'm
really like when I was on Workaholics
you know I this is gonna sound crazy to
people but I never watched Workaholics
you know I didn't watch it it wasn't for
me they weren't speaking to me that
wasn't my my that wasn't my jam
you know it just and then like with the
scripts for Workaholics it would be like
Montez enters with Bill
says nonsense and leaves and now and
that would happen like once or twice in
an episode there was no need to read the
whole script you know these guys would
be like did you read
no I read montez's part I know I'm gonna
come in it has it has nothing to do with
this story it doesn't move the story it
just it's just Montez says nonsense you
know leaves leaves room and you never
see him again
um that's all that you know that's all
it is right so then and then even
sometimes when it was like
oh it was like you know even in like um
um murder mystery murder mystery was
like I was hired way late
it was just like an opening scene
with Sandler and then like another scene
a phone call scene and that was it
there's no need to read the whole script
I don't care it's like I don't care what
happens like I can read my little part
and be like oh okay I know what this
nonsense is
so now cut to your number two on the
call sheet and uh indie
com dramedy sort of you know it's like a
comedy dramedy right and there's arcs
now you know so now your character
starts this way
and then it ends up this way
so it's like
you have to like know the whole script
what I learned yesterday it's like you
have to sort of like memorize everything
know the material backwards and forwards
so because
we don't shoot you shoot out of order
too so like you you might like day one
might be page 20 on the script and you
have to know that oh by date by this
point in the script I'm feeling a
certain way because of things that have
happened on page four
and it's a new it's new it's like it's
new for me you know it's challenging but
like so I'm super open to the whole
process
and I love working with people who are
like uh you know listening and I in that
sort of if you're trying to be an actor
out there my biggest advice for you
is like listen
like truly listen and trust your
instincts even in the scene so like if
if the if the if the actor is giving you
your your scene partner is giving you
something that makes you you would feel
the way that you're you want to react to
certain way then react that way
because then
when it's time to stop and talk about
the scene you know someone might be like
um oh I don't know if that's the the
director writer or whoever's in charge
might be like oh that's not the reaction
we wanted right there but your point is
like well but this is the reaction I'm
going to give if this is what this
person's going to give me and then
you're all working together because in
this book your partner might be like oh
you know what I'm I need I might need to
take some emotions off of that or so I
can guide lead you in a different way
but you just gotta trust and listen you
know you can't just be in a scene and
just do whatever you think you want to
do you think well this is what I think
this is no you have to like and that's
that's like that's the give and take
that's like this like symbiotic
relationship that you have with
everybody on set you know uh with with
the the with the lighting with the where
the camera is you know you have a
relationship with all these things
because you know you you you might know
that the camera is like over here and
it's giving you so you know that you
need to be seen right there so you you
get to move a certain way you know you
know make sure that you're not off
camera make sure you're not back and all
of these things are like listening and
being aware and using all your senses
and it's just like it's um it's very
challenging
you know what I mean it's very it's very
it's very challenging uh and it's great
you know I realize it's like why why do
I
why do I enjoy acting it's like for this
reason right here it's just like you
know you take somebody's words somebody
else's words and make them their your
own
breathe life into this like character
that's not you and maybe
you know maybe this is just a portion of
who you are maybe this is someone you've
always wanted to be and how you get to
be this person or sometimes it's someone
you're like uh I would never be this
person and you're tapping into places in
yourself that you'd be like I'm glad I
don't live like this all the time you
know so it's not a natural thing you
know what I mean it's not you know makes
you uh
it could be weird so but regardless
I'm looking forward to doing this
project so I'm going to be super busy
you know it's like I don't even know
like I might my podcast I might have to
like I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to do my podcast live on Wednesdays uh
in September uh I just I just thought
about that so it might be one of these
things it's like get home late I might
or I might do it like you know I get
offset and I'll do it late at night I'll
have to schedule and see how it goes so
look out for that
um actually moving forward but anyways
shout out to that all right uh what else
we got going on today is
um man dude
um it looks like like lizzo dude
like she
you know we talked about I talked about
it last week man
I mean they
like
the internet Justice is Swift
like the amount of people that have
turned on lizzo and just like I don't
even know I don't even know how I feel
about it the thing is like I don't know
lizzo
I don't know if this stuff is true or
not but it doesn't matter if it is
like it doesn't matter like she has been
tried by the internet Court found guilty
and everyone has turned their back on
her
I mean a shout out to Beyonce by the way
because Beyonce and that's why my title
today is called no loyalty you know like
loyalty is not something that people
care about anymore there's no loyalty
there's no loyalty
you know it's like
people make a calculation a self-serving
calculation in the entertainment
business now
and and everyone because of everyone's
silence
throughout the whole process
you know this is what happens
so this is the calculation people go so
say an allegation comes out about
someone or some bad press comes out
about someone
and if you know this person if you're
friends with this person if you're a
colleague of this person even if it's a
casual relationship with this person you
make the calculation that it is better
to turn on this person to shun this
person and be with the mob and lose that
relationship that's the calculation
people make they go I rather lose that
relationship and be perceived as a good
person
than to show any kind of loyalty because
on the internet if you're friends with
someone who has an allegation against
them it means you condone it that's what
the internet thinks
even though
like even though we know nothing
so like if you're friends with lizzo if
you've worked with her before now all of
a sudden you have to be like oh well I'm
done with her
where it's like did you talk to her do
you know what's going on
I would I bet that we don't know all the
information about this you know and
even if it comes out let's say it comes
out as like she was a she was doing all
this stuff and she was like you know
maybe she wasn't uh a nice person you
know what I mean she was out here being
a boss and like you know telling people
or whatever she was like feeling her
hype you could still be her friend
like you can still be friends with
someone and be like that have gone
through something and done something bad
and be like yo come on like behind the
scenes
I don't have to share that with the
internet
that's what the internet thinks the
internet thinks that we that people have
to share every intimate moment every
conversation they have to explain every
relationship to the internet you don't
have to
but no one appreciates loyalty
you know what I mean
nobody appreciates loyalty
so
I've said it in the past I think that
lizzo shouldn't have been hanging out
with her employees
you know they're on the record it's
talking about some of the things I've
read is that like some of these these
dancers were already reprimanded for
their uh how they were acting on the
road
you know
um you know this was denying all of this
she's like this is like my character's
in question so now we don't know and the
sad part about it is
not that we will ever really know but
the internet doesn't care so the
Judgment has been made lizzo's out
you've been canceled we're moving on
from you there's not gonna be any
retractions there's not going to be any
like follow-up stories there's not gonna
be any stories they're not gonna come
out and be like Oh turns out this was a
frivolous lawsuit in and uh you know
um actually it's like that's never going
to come out it's like these news outlets
are like we're gonna ruin her because
that sells papers that's get that gets
clicks and when you get these clicks on
the websites there's nothing but ads I'm
going to show you an example of what I'm
talking about right now and and even the
headlines you know like so this headline
right here is crazy man
so I think I think Megan Kelly's on Fox
whatever but she goes the headline is
Megan Kelly defends morbidly obese
lizzo's rights to Fat shame her dancers
and suggest that assume the risk of
uncomfortable sexual scenarios by
working for a degenerate
okay what a headline right
oh my my God what a damning headline you
know because I'm not necessarily I don't
I don't condone any bad behavior but I
already said I don't think we know what
really happened but I do support
lizard's the boss she's the star of the
show I don't care if she's fat or not
she's the star if she don't want her
dancers to be a certain way that's her
right you know this is her vision
so but like the way this so This Daily
Mail
look at this page guys
and you wonder why they write articles
like this
look at this it's all advertisement the
whole thing on the page is advertisement
it's like so are you really giving us
news or is this like is this all click
bait is that what it's all about
so so what I'm saying is like I because
I'm I'm in my I'm 51. so
and we were probably wrong in the past
but it looked in the past
you would use the newspapers and
magazines and and and
um news on TV is like if it got there it
must be true
that is a school of thought that people
had okay that's just how we thought
about the world if it was on the news it
must be true because we thought that
these news outlets and newspapers had
some sort of Integrity that they had
some sort of laws that they had to like
follow and they couldn't put false
things in their paper and so if it made
it to the news we would be like well
this must be true Well turns out that's
not true y'all
it's just not true like this is all
click bait Society
and I wish that they I wish it was that
way I wish that if an article about
someone came in the paper that we would
know well they must have evidence that
this is true
but
it turns out it's not it turns out that
they don't have evidence this is all
speculation it's all allegations it's
all you know it it's stirring up
people's feelings so people could be
like oh let me go see what's happening
talk about it on podcasts or whatever
right and then you know it just just to
ruin someone's life to get clicks
okay
now if all of this stuff is true
and then how about this too it's like
how many people were so silent
so now all of a sudden
people are coming out like a director is
like yeah you know what I was working
with her and turns out she's a terrible
person another person is like oh yeah I
used to work for her and but it's like
where the [__] were you when this was
going on where were you
everybody's silent you know everybody's
silent because
and and it's like I don't actually fully
blame people for this because it's all
this like weird circle of life in terms
of like all the the crap people get so
like if you would have come out if six
months ago you would have come out and
said something about lizzo
you'd be oh you're fat shaming or you're
racist it's like well she's black that's
why you're saying this she's fat that's
why you're saying this she's a queen you
know it's like you know now all these
people are coming out like oh well
actually this is how I really feel about
obesity this is what I really feel about
like and now all everybody's got their
things because they've now it's so now
it's okay
that's cowardly
you know what I mean
I don't it's just like
you know you get I guess you got to be a
nice person right
because now more than ever
the lesson you learn from this is like
treat people well because
later it's gonna come out it's gonna
come out like this and it's going to be
presented in a way that you're going to
be looked at as a monster
no matter who it is
no matter who it is you know but there's
no like I say there's no there's no
loyalty people make that calculation in
their head they go oh people are not
liking this person anymore
oh oh allegations came out oh well you
know what that person's the devil and
now I have to come out and let everybody
know I I disassociate myself with this
person because Hey listen
I'm telling you right now that having
loyalty for your friends is not bad
and whatever you do behind the scenes
with your friend to talk to them about
what they've done or what people are
saying they've done or you know or or
whatever their part is in this to make
this come out like this
you can have private conversations with
them to be like yo yo what you doing
like I would hope people around lizard
will be like girl what's going on like
if I was in lizzo's Camp I'd be like
girl you shouldn't be hanging out with
your employees these are these are
employees you know don't be drinking
with your employees
um hey you know what
um stay humble
you know I try to be like that with Matt
Rife I'll tell him
I keep it 100 with him you know when
he's he he might hit me up and be mad
about some stuff I'll be like Yo dude
don't be don't be Petty about that
you don't need to you don't need to do
that I make sure like if I see something
around it and that's because I care
about him he's my friend I love this kid
people around lizzo her real friends
I hope that they show her some loyalty
and be like hey girl I support you I'm
I'm sorry that this thing's these things
are happening and point out like you
know you shouldn't have done this this
and this
her friends don't need to say that
publicly to make themselves feel self
feel like they're a good person
I don't care if you think I'm a good
person or not you know it shouldn't be
that it should just be like
being loyal should be celebrated
also there's some value in being loyal
to your friends
you know what I mean
it's like what are we talking about
you know and so again just because you
are loyal to your friend doesn't mean
you condone bad behavior it doesn't mean
that
it's just it's like but the internet is
so absolute
and so
I feel bad like that's what anyways I
want to shout out
shout out to Beyonce actually so there
was one report that Beyonce took her
name out of the song at a concert that
she was like there's some line in the
song and people are saying like oh be
honestly took her name out and then
Beyonce shout out to her because then at
her other concert she she made sure to
say
to like what does she say
um
I love you lizzo on stage so people can
hear it
you know because it's like
yeah good
like it's like what do you go people are
going to be cancel Beyonce and then I
don't know it's just
I think that that's commendable too you
know and again let me say this again
just because
Beyonce is like hey I love you I support
you lizzo doesn't mean she condones bad
behavior she's just showing some support
for her friend
you know what I mean
anyways
that's all I have to say about that
you know
and it's like
anyways it's like that's actually not
all I have to say it's just I hate that
we live in a world that you can't
believe everything you see on
TV the internet
that it's all about click bait and
profit
it's it's all that's all that it is
there's no due process
you know there's no like it's like
reality and a court of law and the
internet Justice it's crazy how far
apart they are
it's crazy we don't know really what's
going on
even something at the highest level of
what's happening to Trump right now
I don't know what's gonna happen
like if this guy runs for office and
wins what was all this
what was did you have any any real
evidence is there anything real
happening because it's supposed to work
like this a person gets accused of
something
the police investigate this
if they have enough evidence they
there's an indictment that indictment
leads to a court trial
you know and then after trial the person
has to defend themselves if they don't
do it successfully they are you know
they're put in jail or they're you know
what I mean or they're convicted of
something you know like there's due
process that is just not happening on
the internet they don't care no one
cares about due process on the internet
no one even cares about what's actually
going on in reality
you know what I mean like a person is
accused of something
there's no arrest there's no court
documents there's no there's nothing
it's just people saying [__] and nothing
happened like like literally zero things
happened in real life but on the
internet they're guilty you're uh
whatever then just put whatever they
were accused of now it's that you're
this because I saw it on the internet I
you know what I mean like we don't know
what we we don't know what happened
we don't know what happened
and they don't actually have to tell us
because in the real world there's due
process
but now
when companies come in and get involved
and they they make that's the
calculation I said earlier they make
that calculation you know the companies
make account Adidas what they did with
Kanye West Adidas made a calculation
they went oh man and they didn't want to
trust me they didn't want to and they
were like oh man Kanye what do you why
did you go so hard in the paint about
Jews if you didn't want to be in this
contract you know let's work it out but
you had to do it like that so he then
they went uh there was a moment I'm sure
they were like oh my God we're going to
lose they had to they had to sign a
billion dollar check really
in in Goodwill
you know so I think this was like okay
well here's what we have to do all right
we have to cut ties with this guy and
they lost billions
right was it worth it because all the
people did all the people that that that
that that that
all the people that virtue signaled and
came out and was like Adidas you how
could you be in business with him did
they go out and be like when when they
canceled their contract with with uh
Adidas did they then go out and be like
because you did that we're gonna go buy
your products they didn't do that right
I think if they would I think they could
have weathered the storm I think they
could have just been like look
the dude made a mistake uh you know uh
we don't agree with the things he's
saying but here we go like we talked
about this on the golden hour right
check out the golden hour about lizzo
like lizzo was removed from the Super
Bowl halftime
I hope DeSean Watson makes it to the
Super Bowl
I hope he makes it to the Super Bowl
that would be great
the hypocrisy of it all
imagine Cleveland with DeSean Watson is
in the Super Bowl and lizzo
can't perform
with no trial or nothing just you know
you know what I mean like
just y'all wants to settled with all
these women he basically admitted like
he was like yeah I uh you know uh I uh
he acted like apologize
ah man
that would be poetic that would be like
what up like that would be put in our
faces are complete hypocrisy if that
happened but who knows but anyways
um
it is what it is man
so I just I hope that you know I hope
that you're out there and you you know
you want to you
just have your own thoughts you know
what I mean like just because you see
something on the Internet it doesn't
mean that it's real
you know uh and it doesn't mean that
it's not real either that's the thing we
actually don't know enough information
this is not enough information that
people give like this we don't know
what's going on behind the scenes and
you have to understand the motivation of
like a lot of these news out news
outlets is just for clicks
is just for clicks man you know uh any
because you go to the website that you
clicked because you saw this headline
and then you look and it's like you're
just it's like being at a stadium you
ever been to like a a basketball game
you know football game at a live man
there isn't a direction you can look
without seeing ads
it's like this is brought to you by this
that's brought to you by that and then
you just kind of like you just got to
focus on the game but if you just look
up a little bit and you'll see an ad
next time you go to a game I just want
you to look in any direction and you
will see an ad yeah we have to remember
that that is the reason why this kind of
stuff is put out without all the facts
you know what I mean
um you know it's something else man
it's crazy
um you know
the
yeah man
huh
yeah so
I see uh somebody in the chat is asking
about that uh Blind Side Story you know
with some questions in here well let me
go to the questions in the chat room oh
man wow it's already 45 minutes it's
crazy I'm really going in today I didn't
even get to the stuff I wanted to talk
about
any thoughts on the preseason football I
will do a preseason football thing I
have I haven't started talking about
football yet but I will when is the baby
dude
sometime in January it looks like
January 27th is the date I will be
getting on Twitch if I can have any
guests on my pod who would it be
um I'd love to talk to Bieber love to
sit down and find out what's going on in
his head you know
um
um are you gonna find out the gender oh
I already you you don't you're not a fan
because I've already put that
information out
um what are my plans on Pro my
professional life and fatherhood I have
no idea that is such a great question I
don't know how I'm gonna balance this
all I don't know what's going to happen
I'm probably gonna have to game less I'm
probably gonna have to like I don't know
what I'm gonna do actually it's like
I've lived my whole life like I've lived
a full life I feel like you know and now
I have to like start a whole new chapter
of life and how to you know so we'll see
I'm gonna that's a great question and
I'll keep you guys posted on that
um let's see do I do I like Star Wars
games
um yeah
you know and then like the next thing is
like I'm looking for I'm I'm looking for
like in my neighborhood where I live is
I'm looking for like a trainer I'm
looking for some some some place to go I
got my my my
week on my rowing machine and just being
100 honest I haven't been on it in you
know a little while
so I just I gotta I have to now I'm
planning on like this last five months
before this baby is due is like I'm
gonna take this five months and just
really work on me getting a routine so I
could be healthy you know
so
you know hold me accountable you know
what I mean
I think I'm not I'm not one of these
people that's like oh you're fat shaming
that thing like shame is good I think
when somebody is like hey what's going
on you don't gotta be mean about it
though that's the thing you know you
could be like hey man I think you should
get in shape but be like you know what
you're right you know but anytime I see
something like that though I still I'm
like oh you know what I don't like
people saying that you know like like
even this picture of me and Matt I saw
myself and I was like damn I look huge
and I was like uh oh so it really
inspired me I was like oh I I got to get
myself together so you know that's like
an important uh thing and you know being
a father is just being able to be there
you know they they come running down the
street I gotta be able to run after them
or something right I can't be like slow
down that and have a heart attack when
my kid is running into traffic you know
what I mean so those are the kind of
things you have to think about
um all right uh let's I want to go over
this uh story real quick uh because we
only got a little bit of time left so
um
there was this like dude did you guys
see this uh did you guys see this
freaking
woman
and her and her python
you know
I won't even have look at this [__] this
snake attacks her right and
you know they're trying okay oh oh let's
get the snake off for her right and then
the guy filmed he's like should I stop
filming and they're like no keep filming
and then you know they're just kind of
and then like their whole attitude is
like
you know it's like oh snakes are good
don't worry this is this doesn't
normally happen and then they're trying
to like get this snake off of her let me
be perfectly clear
for all you idiots out there who always
send messages about oh snakes are pets a
snake is not a pet okay
pets
know their pets all right
like when a dog bites its owner we kill
that [__] it's gone okay when a
when a dog bites the owner we go well
the dog has now realized uh the dog has
now lost it we gotta put it down
that's what happens
in these situations that's what happens
but with this we want to act like well
you know look
if your pet quote unquote
if it gets hungry or agitated and it
will attack you
that's not a pet
hello
even cats have the respect to only eat
you after you're dead Okay they always
say like a cat will eat its owner if
they die because the cat's like well I'm
hungry so you know dogs don't do that
dogs will die next to their owner but
cats will but the cats wait at least
look at this this chick is [__]
bleeding you know what I mean it's like
when I see that
I have absolute
zero sympathy for any
owner of a monkey that gets their face
gnawed off anybody that has a cat or a
spider you know what I mean like you you
get people that got tarantula aquariums
and stuff
if you get bit
bye
bye I have this woman I have zero
sympathy for her
you think
yeah you know when you see like
a dude that works with lions he got one
hand and one leg
and you're like
and then they blame themselves they go
well you know that's my mistake oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's your mistake your
mistake was thinking that that's not a
wild ass animal
that was your mistake
python wants to be in it's little ass
cage this python is like okay
you need you gave me two mice um when
I'm out in the jungle I could get as
many eat as much as I want now I have to
be on your food schedule
like this python is like yo [__] get me
out of here
it's crazy
I
I mean I
so many people like we talked about this
on the golden hour King in this thing
and these like snake people be like oh
Griffin you don't know what you're
talking about nah man
you don't know what you're talking about
okay
you that's not a pet okay
snakes are not a pet you're an abuser
all right that's what you are that that
that pet that snake has been kidnapped
and trust me it's acting okay now
because it's trying to escape and the
first chance it gets to bite you and try
to get the hell out of there it will
take it
nonsense
okay
what else we got here
oh man I have my internet I have my
crazy internet stories let's just go
through them briefly let's go through
them briefly you know
um here we go social media Madness I'm
so sick of hearing about Mark Zuckerberg
and Elon Musk are they gonna fight or
not like who cares you rich [__]
who cares okay
this that's gonna be the saddest fight
ever talk about
Rich entitlement like what I I the fact
I'm so mad at myself that I even have to
talk about this who cares who cares guys
move on you're destroying the world with
your nonsense you have too much money
too much influence too much power and
you're distracting us with this [__]
move on
so sick of them
next
this was hilarious to me speaking of
spiders
see Australia
I don't know if you've ever been in
Australia they got wild ass animals just
all over the place dangerous so this
this spider
oh Austrian not even Australia oh this
is I don't even see I thought it was
Australia it's Austrian this that's even
this is crazy Austrian Supermarket shut
down due to spider that can cause long
painful
erections
wow
I mean
talk about
erectile dysfunction and they
I didn't even know
Austria had this kind of animal problem
but damn Matthew gets bit by a spider
and you were just rock hard and can't
you just like
oh man I'm running out of time you know
what we're gonna come back to the we're
gonna come back to the rock hard
erections on another episode and shout
out to Cristiano Ronaldo for being the
first person on to have 600 million
followers like my goodness isn't it
crazy that these soccer players have
this like 600 million followers and
we're just kind of like blah about
soccer in the United States like that's
like how influential is this guy that he
has 600 million followers
all right guys I'm watching this show
Invasion on
um yeah I'm watching this show Invasion
on Apple TV oh I really think I I really
like it it's this uh so Earth is visited
by alien species that threatens Humanity
existence events unfold in real time
Through The Eyes of five Ordinary People
so what I like about this show and I I'm
realizing more and more that I love when
shows deal with relationships and how
whatever the events of the Sci-Fi sci-fi
fantasy world that they've created for
us how the people maneuver through that
and the relationships that happen I
think is the is that's what it's really
about that's what makes it really good
to me because but if you want to see
like alien stuff I mean oh man you not
you you're not going you're gonna be
disappointed if you're looking for like
alien fighting and really seeing the
monsters in the first seven episodes you
know what I mean it's crazy but it's a
great building of relationships and
following these people and how they're
dealing with this and so that's what I
do like about about it because they
actually film like it's like throughout
the episodes it's like people it's not
like everybody knows each other it's
like they're going to like five
different places like they're in Japan
they're in like they're following this
Soldier they're following these British
kids they're following this couple uh
who like to you know they're going
through some marital issues and then
they then there's during an alien
invasion how would you deal with that
right and they got kids and you know so
I think it's a good watch I I would
recommend it I recommend watch if you
have Apple TV I would recommend watching
Invasion somebody recommended it and
chat one day and so I actually watched
it and I you know I I think it's
completely worth watching so
I'll do a more extensive uh review on uh
riffing with Griffin and I mean on you
know for patreon check that out you know
but guys I wanna I wanna thank everybody
for watching the podcast I really
appreciate you guys as always you know
make sure you subscribe to the channel
uh hit the notifications so you can get
uh you know you know when I'm going live
right you know when I'm putting up
because I'm putting up stand up videos
you know I'm doing all that so make sure
you uh you know make sure you you get on
there so you can see when that's coming
on you know I'm always on Twitch I'll be
on Twitch sometime later today
me and my boys we did that we did that
carnivore diet sketch we're doing some
more sketches today so I'm going to go
film that right after this I actually
have to bust out of here that's why I'm
kind of rushing to finish
um so make sure you guys check that out
and as I said make sure you hit the the
like subscribe and if you want to you
know you could be a twitch
you know you could be a you could be a
twitch follower
um
you know subscriber to help support me
it could be a patreon you could be a
YouTube member those are all the
different ways that you could support me
on um
you know support the show man so I do
appreciate you guys constantly being
here you guys have been great and you
know what time it is
oh it's time for that rat recap
lizzo got clapped
um now she back
everybody calling her fat
what they lack
loyalty loyalty
here on breaking with Griffin
everybody was so goddamn worried about
it oh yeah
you know Apple TV
watch Invasion so you can see
that's a good show
on this Eric Griffin flip
now you know
Daddy got
ta show some loyalty
hey show some loyalty
[Music]
I thank you for your loyalty watching
river with Griffin if you want to send
me a beat for the rap recap just send me
an email to Eric airgriffin.com guys
thanks for watching we're from with
Griffin and I'll see you next week
[Music]